[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 201 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I
am Sean Foust and I'm here with my
teammate Brian Dorsey hey Brian how's it
going good hello hello everyone looking
forward to a good show this episode were
actually joined by Maria Lourdes Cody
from face it she's a director of
business intelligence and they're doing
a lot of work in reducing toxicity and
text and voice chat for games and you
know I love games Brian so it's
definitely going to be very interesting
that's awesome and I'm really looking
forward to it that's an incredibly
important area right make things better
online very excited to actually have
Maria because it's not very often that
we have many women who are in the gaming
room I'm particularly excited to have
Marie on this episode awesome looking
forward to it also we're going to get
into our question of the week Brian's
gonna dive in on this it's when I SSH
into my VM via different methods you
know cloud console G cloud any other
method that you would like to use I get
a different user name each time what can
I do to make that static SSH and Google
cloud and VM I'm excited but before that
let's get into our cool things of the
week
[Applause]
got two weeks worth so it was a hard
thing to choose there's lots of extras a
few highlights one thing that jumped out
at me is we've got a new series of
trainings specifically for business
people who are want to kind of go deep
on the business ends of Google Cloud so
most of our trainings have been you know
for hands-on technical folks and this is
geared more towards kind of making sense
of the business decisions and how you
balance trade-offs there so excited
about that there's three of them to
start business transformation with
Google cloud machine learning for
business professionals and leading
change in the cloud era so that'll be
good to check out if that's you or if
there is a kind of a business II person
on your team who you'd like to help get
a little more bootstrap to Google cloud
send them this way so one of my cool
things of the week is the addition of
Microsoft sequel servers to our cloud
sequel portfolio this is great because
there are a lot of benefits that come
along with it and especially with a lot
of our users who are more accustomed to
using Microsoft sequel server if you're
used to it the great thing is that we're
offering multiple editions with the
current version of sequel server which
is great and you can also use profitable
clients to manage that using such as
sequel server management studio and the
other key benefits include flexible
backups scalability and high end
availability this would be great so
there's a lot of which isn't this fall
over
scaling whenever you reach your limit
and daily automatic backups or you can
run them on demand
that's awesome me too I know you know
the people who use a lot of sequel
server it has so many features use a lot
of them you need sequel server and it's
great that that's available on a nice
managed fashion now so next up kind of
continuing the data theme is post
recently on how to orchestrate the data
preparation side of things like kind of
ETL kind of perspective for getting data
into databases or preparing it for
machine learning ai kind of back ends
and so there's this article how to
orchestrate cloud data prep jobs using
cloud Composer
which I wanted to highlight and data
prep is an integrated version of this
tool called Wrangler from trifecta and
it helps kind of both visually
interactive and like run batch jobs
around the full set of data preparation
stuff you'd want to do and see anomaly
isn't all kinds of good stuff and then
cloud Composer is managed apache airflow
which
is a workflow management tool which is a
little abstract but I think about it
kind of like executable flowcharts when
you draw those like whiteboard diagrams
about if this then do that so you can
actually make code that makes those
decisions and execute them like running
sub processes or calling api's and
things like that and this is a really
great example of setting up a full clean
preparation pipeline using those tools
together so check it out
yeah that actually sounds pretty amazing
I'm probably gonna check that out myself
so following on the AI trend our AI
platform prediction allows data
scientists to serve models for online
predictions in a serverless environment
so we're announcing a couple updates to
that you can now choose from a set of
compute engine scene types to run your
model and you can add GPUs such as the
inference optimized low latency and
Vijay 84 so it's actually very powerful
GPU you can actually add that to your
actual run your model and then the other
features that we include are custom
containers and compute engine machine
types for training so you can choose any
combination of CPUs Ram and accelerators
and then for our containers they become
very useful because you can work with
any model framework or dependency if
you're interested in it please check it
out that sounds great
skimming the article looks like you know
basically having a new back-end on
kubernetes engine is what allows this so
that's a great segue into the GK team
kubernetes engine team has added
detailed usage metering as a feature and
that's just gone Gao generally available
so all supported and ready to use and
what that gives you is monitoring down
at the pod level and then aggregating
that up to the namespaces in kubernetes
or to labels that you give on the pods
so that you can see exactly how much
usage is happening from each of the
teams that are working on things or
different programs or any other
dimension that you care about and the
reason I'm excited about this and wanted
to highlight it is that at some level
getting high utilization like lots of
usage out of the computers you buy or
rent it's kind of the point of
containers and getting that without
having the the programs conflict with
each other so like you really want to
push the high utilization to get your
money's worth out of these systems and
this helps you seeing where that's
happening and where it's not so that
wraps it up for our cool things with
week
and we're pretty excited to get to our
guests Maria so let's go talk to Maria
[Music]
hi and on this episode we're joined by
Maria scurry from face it
so Maria pleasure to have you would you
like to tell us who you are and what you
do sure well thanks a lot for having me
today
it's great to be here so yeah John was
saying I work at face it and I'm the
director of business intelligence which
I think you can summarize that into two
main things on one side we try to do a
lot of machine learning and artificial
intelligence so many topics and then on
the other side what we really want is to
drive the culture inside our business
inside our company so to make people
understand how they can use data and how
that can be used to get insights on your
day to day so making sure that when we
release a new feature we can actually
measure the impact instead of just
saying oh no we think that's gonna do
great but then you can't quantify that
great so yes that's what we're trying to
do here that's awesome and I've actually
heard quite a bit about you bunch of
Googlers actually told me about the work
that you do the work that face it does
and we just had to have you on the
episode today so can you tell us a
little bit more about what face it is
doing so face it is a competitive gaming
platform which I guess hasn't done much
if you're outside of gaming so to
clarify I think you can think about face
it kind of like it's a a marketplace in
a way so on one side you have gamers
players that want to take part in two
different competitions that can range
from our own private ari matchmaking to
a different type of tournaments so
you've got leagues got round-robin
Championships you've got this standard
single bracket tournament and then on
the other side we have lots of people in
each person the competitive gaming that
are actually spending their lives
organizing these competitions and it
ranges from like guys at school at
university that won't organize they're
on a university league to like
professional businesses there's like
many organization in the sector that are
organizing different types of
competitions what face it does it's just
trying to get people together so on one
side we have players and on the other
side we have organizers and we're just
basically trying to get them to me
each other so we have like several
system that on the platform actually
facilitate players to find the right
competition that kind of matches their
own interest gotcha
so you've got like strong competition
online gaming so I imagine everything
always goes smoothly what's been a core
for us but it was so like for game
publishers as well because we work
closely with a lot of game publisher so
one of the things that we have is just
like a very smooth integration with the
game so it's very easy basically with
the click of a button you got to face it
to the game and things are not always
that smooth when you actually like put
several people that don't know each
other that well into the same online
scenario I think like toxicity has
always been a big issue in gaming it's
defiantly an issue for us as well I
think it's probably due to like some of
the aspects about matchmaking or in
general like the gaming experience
unfitted for example just to give you an
example we have a hundred thousand
concurrent players at the same time you
need to just ten of them to make a match
and honestly the likelihood that after
this match you're gonna encounter again
it's likely the same other nine players
it's like close to zero
you're probably social inhibitions that
you would have in a like another
environment like probably as school
you're not gonna just go in into the
classes start insulting somebody because
then like you're faced with that every
day no but in gaming well I mean I'm
probably spending like thirty minutes of
my life with these other nine people and
I think the other guy has just done
something that is really stupid I'm
gonna say that to him I can I'm probably
actually get a sailor in not such a
polite way and I think that's in the end
it's like an issue to online behavior
especially anywhere you're online you're
also like with video games in general
but in other situations as well your age
yourself but you're also using an avatar
to go around and I think already that
puts some of the social inhibitions that
you may be having other context those
are lower down so you've got a
whole group of people everyone with kind
of lowered social inhibitions
you know stressful environment things
can go poorly pretty easily huh yes if
you get like already people starting
with lower inhibitions that and then
here at on top that especially on face
it like the environment is really really
competitive because of different reasons
like on one side we have a warlike path
to become a professional player and to
actually get the occasion to be noticed
so as you rank up on face it you can end
up in our face it pro league where for
contest record sample lots of
professional players so they actually be
in talent scouted from there well in
some tournaments you might be competing
for money as well so I think the two
things together then you could have a
bomb that it's about to explode in a way
there's like lots of tension that
especially if you're seeing that the
match is not really going in your
direction there there's lots of tensions
and builds up and the way that's
expressed in some cases well not all the
times but in quite a few cases can be
like pretty toxic honestly so I am a
very competitive gamer myself actually
had a meeting earlier this week with
Brian and actually told them that I was
gaming for 20 hours straight and I can
tell you that after gaming for 20 hours
your personality will definitely change
although it's not really you that people
see when they're at gaming I can say
that after a while and once I was on a
pretty good winning streak and I was
just really excited to finally be back
to my rank that I believe I born in I
can tell you that you start to judge
people quite often so the question I
really have is what are you really doing
to address the toxicity in message
because there are different forms of
toxicity throwing games there's verbal
there's text so what are you really
doing to address that and how does face
it address it so I think we are trying
to get like quite any nobody approach
when it comes to that so firstly we
started with text shot and that's
something that we actually had a case
study published by jigsaw how we are
using an integrating perspective API so
one of the Google tools into our system
but on the other hand we do know that
there's more to it so text is probably
just one of the ways that succeeds it is
clearly
facing but as you were saying there's
just so many different behaviors that
you can annoy people with so if we take
counter-strike you could be griefing so
you maybe you're just blocking the
passage to somebody there's moisture
could kill it teammate so there's many
different things so what we are really
trying to do is simply build a
comprehensive system that is going to be
able to analyze and understand each of
these different behaviors so we see text
shot is just like the very first
milestone for what we are actually
building and one of the next step that
we have for example is we are building a
UI and that's going to involve our
community to actually help us understand
what they see as toxic because I think
that's also the other problem that
you're actually trying to solve is also
toxicity is a perception of toxicity mmm
you don't have a clear cut there was
defiantly toxic especially when it comes
to certain behavior like there's two
things that you always need to evaluate
that's intention on one side and
actually if that was perceived as toxic
us there are some situations where for
example even if what you're saying it
could be in some scenarios considered
toxic but maybe if I'm in a group of
friend and that's qualified as Bunter so
there's like all these different nuances
that are not that easy to understand on
one side and then yeah on the other side
what we are really trying to do and what
our system basically looks like we are
getting data from different sources so
we take that shot we take moisture we
also basically have the UI extreme in
HTTP stream of every event that happened
in the game and we are recording this
set of events so we know like for
example if in a match somebody who
started a vote to kick somebody else we
know if there was a team key all we know
if there were other signals on the basis
of all these different sources the first
step that we want to do is basically
create cases that our players are going
to help us label so the first step is
let's make this interface like this
system that we actually are gonna
release in in probably a month it's
gonna go home
but yeah the first step would be let's
get the input from our players to help
us actually understand what's going on
and label all this data and then this is
gonna fit into probably two different
models that are gonna then be able to
analyze each stream and then finally get
like a comprehensive understanding of
what really got went on
okay so just measuring all of this is a
real challenge you described a couple of
scenarios so those are some of your
inputs and you get some of the labeling
is it all just labeling labeling is just
the first step then basically what we're
doing is so if we take the chart
toxicity as an example case we send
almost 200 million messages to
perspective API for each of those
messages we got the score back then we
went in we actually Hannah lies the
discourse so we were getting because the
score by itself in might not necessarily
mean that of course like the higher the
score is close to 1 the more toxic that
message should be perceived but the
other part that we were interested in as
well from our side was to also try to
understand okay what is the full
sentiment in that match so it's not just
about the single comment but it's also
that that C city usually builds other
two CCD so we also wanted to take the
world shot into consideration so on top
of that we actually built our on machine
learning model to basically get to a
final score for that user in that match
on the basis of that score then minor
which is basically our admin AI so we
are basically just trying to replicate
what a human moderator would do if we
were able to have somebody have enough
people to moderate 5,000 concurrent
matches or 10,000 concurrent matches
then you probably would but that's like
it doesn't really scale that well so
yeah like on the basis of what this
final score then Minerva takes a certain
action either warns the player or issues
a ban I think it was a two side of
things one thing was firstly
implementing a perspective in this case
then it was a lot of understanding what
that score actually mean but also what
that score means relative to our
specific
population because especially with the
system like perspective that was built
like for a brother scenario that's like
online perception of child and how like
each comment can affect the conversation
I think it's important to understand
like relate that with your own use case
because probably like moderating a
gaming community of eighteen to twenty
five years old it's very different than
my grandmother
today was wanted to read an article on
the times and was shocked about like her
specific comments that honestly in the
context of gaming that would have been
like totally accepted a little bit of
different like of differentiation that
that you need to do and as you need to
consider and then I think on top of that
is also now you've got your mushy
learning model you've got your metric so
in our case is this metric that tries to
define let's say the level of chat
toxicity of the user in that and then
you could have another metric that is
defining the level of voice toxicity the
user had in the match and then you're
gonna have a third metric that tries to
understand their behavior and then you
can try to understand how the well you
will need to try to understand how these
metrics are gonna coexist with each
other in our case what we are trying to
do is punish the behavior rather than
the user so we are trying to make a
distinction about your heart being toxic
versus you did something toxic and we
are trying to go in the second direction
so we are really trying to say you did
something toxic that you should have
been done but that doesn't qualify you
as a person
so in our case in this example like if
here were toxic in the child and then
probably like Tim killed somebody it
would be he should two different bands
and those bands and those warnings would
be targeted to the behavior because
ultimately what we are trying to do is
also pinpoint exactly what you did wrong
and allow you to understand what
happened and possibly learn from it
that's like the part that we're really
interested in and how we really wanna
try to do is actually like finding away
inside
of punishing toxicity can we prevent
toxicity and can we do something that
actually changes the behavior of our
user of our players and potentially
changes it for the batter and so for us
it was really important and that's like
something that was great with
perspective for example for the texture
and the mother we are developing was
actually also being able to tell the
users this is what you said this is how
is escalating and this is why it's not
it's at the ball and we really valued
that feedback that we can give I'm kind
of curious because you've mentioned that
you currently use in our perspective API
and you're using this to build out a
bunch of models I'm curious a sovereign
prospective API are you utilizing any
other GCP products to address issues in
gaming and I've always thought about
toxicity is something that is a real big
issue in gaming bring send it myself how
do you deal with it culturally as well
because you can see that maybe in
certain cultures certain phrasing and
certain words are not considered like an
insults or toxic whereas in another
country it may be completely
unacceptable so like in terms of Phi to
CP Prada yeah
using a lot--but query Google to query
it's basically the basis of any machine
learning that we want to do because
that's where we do all our data
exploration so everything that happens
on the platform it's fat into bigquery
so on B query we basically have all our
data where else it lives there another
tool that we are using a lot is looker
Google cloud I think acquired a couple
of months ago so like for example you're
using that a lot for data visualization
so we usually do the first like
pre-processing inside bigquery and then
just blot things in looker or we are
using a lot cloud data lab as well
especially because that really
simplifies a lot when you're tackling an
issue like toxicity we are tracking it
in a team of 10 people so it was really
boring for us to be able to collaborate
on Jupiter not books as well and like if
you don't use cloud in a lab but you're
building your own notebook locally then
you need to send that file into an HTML
or like you need to download that file
somehow and then send it to the other
person it needs to work on it then you
need to share it while you yeah you
might be sure
in the codebase and Geeta but sometimes
it's not enough so for example like data
lab was really useful for us because
it's integrated directly with bigquery
so I can easily pull up SQL queries that
you will run on bigquery and you can put
them inside your notebook so that's like
super easy and then on the other side
was very good for us because you can
share them and basically you can have
multiple people working on it so that
was great then of course we're using the
cloud eai platform so we are like
building our machine learning model or
living there we are using mainly
tensorflow
like for example that one of the things
that really helped there is a unphased
we generate lots of data for example
perspective he had 200 million messages
we wanted to analyze and process them
quickly you can simply do that locally
so being on Clyde AI and being able to
spawn a virtual machine where it can
basically process as many data as you
want depending on the machine you're
actually spawning it's simplified the
process a lot I think it took a lot of
headaches away that you don't really
want the data science team to think of
when it comes like your architecture
like you don't want to have DevOps
aspart you know or data science team
that are thinking about how to set up a
virtual machine I just want to get that
the heart like to get that with the
clicker which is something that you can
do one cloud AI which was great yeah and
then actually before we were using a
tool of a compositor but we've seen
today on your cloud AI that you're
actually have a tool for data labeling
so we have sorry testing data which is
in beta right and also we have our data
set being labeled right now on there so
kind of curious about those cultural
differences and how can you consider
what the top second what's not so I
think like there are several things so
on one side when it comes to perspective
API it actually has models in different
languages so right now it is poor
Spanish French and English and then
there are three models that are in beta
which is I think Italian Portuguese and
another one then we have been talking
with them a lot about Russian because we
have a lot of Russian users and that's
like one thing that we need to factor in
of course like right now we are doing
some approximation because like one of
the things are for example we have
to do to score a message was to firstly
send it to Translate API so that's
another Google tool that we are using
getting the translation back and then we
score the translation one thing that we
did to try to minimize the errors and
cultural difference was when we had the
dataset labeled we had it labeled by
people that were from that culture so we
were like splitting the data after that
if like we were asking basically Russian
people to review Russian messages
Italian people through review Italian
messages and so on to actually get an
understanding of the differences right
now what we're really trying to do which
I think kinda minimize that problem in
our use case we are really trying to go
after behavior that are really really
toxic so when we release this first
model into our production system and and
it started automatically warning and
many people to give you an idea we are
basically targeting the top 5% of most
toxic behavior so within that range
yes cultural differences are still there
but not as much because on the opposite
side I do think that is slightly bit of
toxicity it's part of competitiveness I
don't know it's like thinking there are
football players with like lightly
insult themselves on the field it just
feels like it can't get to a point where
you're just basically being the Big
Brother watching on everything and
censoring everything you see what kind
of need to keep it balanced and you need
also done they're still like you can't
go after everything because then you
would kind of put yourself at the
opposite end I would say I don't use the
word banter earlier you know like you've
got this going on yes I think like
there's some banter going on and I think
you don't want to get into a position
that your model is actually like banning
for banter yes you wanna like find that
middle like era then yeah there were
like things that were a bit tricky for
example with using perspective or in
general if the gaming language is a lot
of slang and so that was one of the
tricky bits was actually like to factor
that slang into into our models so there
were like some efforts on that side
we put in and then on the other side is
that things that are not acceptable in
other contexts they're actually standard
terms you know like a game like Counter
Strike global Offensive like for example
if I say nice add shot
Counter Strike it's actually like meant
to be a complete fat outside of it you
might be inciting violence so yeah
there's like context differences so you
know toxicity is a huge challenge
kind of everywhere online right and I
think many of the folks who are
listening are building and running
systems where users interact with each
other do you have recommendations for
them on how to apply some of the things
you've learned in this space I think
it's a choosing like on one side before
using this approach we were trying to go
down the approach that I think it's used
by many that's more like building a
karma system so that tries to get in
index tries to represent how toxic of a
player you are I think in general a
karma system works good when you're
trying to build that as an owner score
like more how good of a player you are
rather than how bad of a player you are
or in general like not just in gaming
but everywhere and I think on one side
is trying to enforce the positive then
on the other side I also think like know
your context so I know what you're
dealing with because I think toxicity
can be so many different things come in
even on let's say like on a social
network I can be toxic by writing a very
very bad comment or I can be toxic by
posting a bad image or I could post a
video that is out of space and those are
all like different data signals when I
say like no your conduct is also know
how to access it it can express itself
and consider like all these different
sources and the fact that you kind of
need to deal with all of them because
otherwise people are smart so if the
people know you cannot write a swear
word in your comment they're probably
gonna put a swear word in your image if
they notice that attacked in the image
so they're gonna think of something else
so you need to know them and you need to
try to use as a comprehensive
approach as you can and then I think the
other side is also celebrate the small
wins it's a huge issue and I think he
needs to be broken down into smaller
ones and then you need to tackle a each
smaller issue one at a time because
otherwise if you're trying to just stuck
everything and then go out with the
super big system that tries to solve it
all you might not get the result instead
I'm thinking like step by step so just
really is the first small thing
see also which affected us because like
one thing is us like we're people so we
learn from things so that's also one of
the things that you want to rely on is
that when you start pushing for change
and hopefully people are gonna follow as
well so they are actually going to help
you what you're doing yeah so you
basically said think about behavior
instead of kind of reputation overall
they're like what people are doing in
the moment that helps with these
short-term things as well I also think
that it happens in many ways like it
I've seen to a certain criticism bother
so I think like that's always something
I've been thinking of and that's why
like that was one of the things that I
really pushed and faced it embraced and
I think yeah we are basically life
trying to build this and then hopefully
maybe in the future this can become a
tool that other game publishers can use
but it's also really like swapping from
criticize you as a person which is
usually not taken that well and also Who
am I to criticize you as a person maybe
are just having a bad day so I'm just
wanna point out that she did something
wrong and I think that's taken a lot
better also not gonna personal point of
view in general like school or such it's
very different when you tell a kid you
did something wrong or instead you tell
them oh you're being a bad kid yeah I
think it's really interesting to hear
about kind of aligning the software
systems to what's actually just
basically good interpersonal human
behavior like it's kind of a classic
recommendation to talk about the
behavior rather than that person I think
we're trying to do is actually like I
think artificial intelligence and
machine learning are as smart as people
are or they can be as smart as people
are and it's not an artificial
intelligences these these magic things
it depends on how you build it so what
we are really trying to build with me
nervous
we can make her think the way we think
in a way so it's more like if there are
practices that are good in human
relations why should we forget about
them when you are in a technological
field and we are trying to build loved
it so if people are motivated and want
to learn more about this space you know
do you have recommendations for where to
go next
besides becoming a super competitive
gamer for sure well there's the case
started I was published today on the
jigsaw blog post so for sure I'll put a
link to that in the notes yeah
perspective API there's lots of good
documentation there there's also like if
you read about toxicity in gaming
there's light lots of articles coming up
about it actually lots of studies from
like a researchers in academia about in
general like how to apply machine
learning and AI on toxicity but as a
general model and then you can always
take like that learning and see how they
feed in your own space can we ask you
for one two three recommendations we can
put in the show notes for specific
papers to look at yeah sure I can send
those o'er is there anything that we've
missed that you would like to mention
before we wrap things up or would you
like to let listeners know where we can
find you and we can find any material
that you're posting so that we can stay
up to date with everything that faceit
is doing yeah sure well London so if
anybody's there happy to Acharya anybody
I'm probably gonna be at GDC as well
face it can find out some medium so blog
tough a sitcom that's a good way to keep
up to speed with what we're doing I'm
quite talkative so there are some blogs
about what we are doing around toxicity
what we want to do and so on and then
face it calm pure gamer and actually
fancy match would be happy to see you
there and I know that you're a gamer
I've never publicly shared my gamer
handle or wit games I play but if you
would like your listeners to probably
hop on the sticks and play with you I
don't know if you want to share your
gamer handles or anything yes face it
Lulu you can find me on League of
Legends
where the Warcraft that's like two main
games but usually like you can find me
around plenty of games awesome and I
guess I'll follow the same
sooo and you can find me mostly on
overwatch and on a world so I'll
definitely link my battle tags on that
as well
Oh new information new things that we
learned about John it's rough out here
thank you so much for spending time with
us and sharing like it really feels like
you're pushing things forward to make
things better for humans interacting
online so thank you so much thank you so
much for having me with pleasure so we
would like to thank our guests Maria for
joining us in this episode it was really
amazing to hear about all the cool
things that face it is doing to pretty
much end toxicity in gaming or put a
dent and I play competitive games quite
often and toxicity is one of the major
things I've contributed myself I'll be
honest but it's really great to see
someone's really trying to make a change
in the gaming space I totally agree and
I'm personally like really looking
forward to seeing
I mean Gaming is a particularly tough
space for this I'm looking forward to
seeing the tools and techniques that
come out of there
hopefully branch into other areas
because we have challenging environments
and pretty much all of our online social
networks so looking forward to seeing
improvements there and hopefully you
know games were meant to bring people
together maybe faces platform will help
bring people closer together by ending
toxicity so so Brian our question the
week is going to be directed straight at
you
[Music]
that question of the week was when is
agents in my VM via different methods I
get a different username so what can I
do to make that static that can be super
confusing because if you're by default
and this is talking about SS aging into
compute engine instances the user name
is kind of just passed through from what
your your kind of host environment is so
if you're on the cloud console that's
going to be the first part of your email
address of whatever you're logged into
google cloud is then if you later go in
SSH in from your laptop you might have a
different user name on your laptop and
then you're logging into the same
machine but you end up with two
different user accounts on that end and
you know your dot files don't work the
same way or you know the permissions
don't work the same way and it gets all
confusing so there's a couple of options
one is that you could change all the
things now that's not so super useful
when you SSH in from your laptop and
this is a feature that might not be that
known so just to talk about it a bit as
part of G cloud there's a g-cloud
compute SSH and then an instance name
and it handles since you're already
logged in with OAuth to the Google cloud
it handles the SSH key pair exchange and
all that sort of stuff for you and just
does all the configuration so you don't
worry about it but one of the things
that does and that automatic thing is
figure out what user to use and I just
infers that from your laptop so the fix
is actually really simple but hard to
notice so it's great if you know it's
there not if you don't and it's
basically you just add instead of just
the instance name user at instance name
and then that will set the remote user
to log into and you're good to go
so g-cloud compute ssh user at instance
and that'll work
so that's the short version there is a
more kind of managed version of SSH keys
that kind of work at the organization
level that's called OS login and if
you're using that when you submit your
SSH key your public key to use the first
time you can also specify the username
that should be used on the instances
there and of course you're logging into
a you know usually a Linux box in this
case for SSH so you can use you know
Unix commands and you can always just
kind of sudo su into the user you want
on the other end as well
wow that's a handful um glad that you
can you know tackle all of those
different yeah that was kind of a lot of
words we'll put a couple links in the
show notes to the docs with some
examples so thanks Brian for tackling
all of those different methods of
actually assessing into your actual GCE
instance glad that you can you know
offer our listeners like multiple
multiple multiple efforts and the
nuances using each one so Brian I want
and curious where you gonna be what are
you doing and the upcoming months yeah
so I've recently switched to being all
in on compute engine and use cases
around that so as part of that I'm kind
of doing a bunch of learning and heads
down time so that's for majority my time
is but I'm also going to be at a
conference called supercomputing that's
in Denver in November interesting
conference is a mix of academia and kind
of industry stuff so excited about that
and I will be at a series of different
places I'll be at anime NYC that's just
a personal thing for me in November
right prior to going to keep Khan and
November we're running our matchmaking
and game server workshop so if you're
going to be there please check us out
and then I get to hang out with our ng
m-- for our open match framework and
Google Kirkland and December and then
I'll probably end up taking like a small
very very small business trip to
Montreal to hang out in meet some gaming
folks and then I go on vacation finally
so yeah I'm really excited to wrap up my
engineer travel and have some fun
sounds good well we would like to thank
you all for listening and Ryan has been
a pleasure as always
likewise so we'll see you all next week
[Music]